اضاءه سماء مدينه خاركيف الاوكرانيه
بالالوان مساء الثلاثاء بعد اصابه مصنع
للالعاب الناريه بضربات روسيه
بعد ساعه من زياره مفاجاه وجريئه لوزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه الى هذه المدينه برفقه
نظيره الاوكرانيه برلين ستقدموا مساعده
لاوكرانيا لازاله الالغام وتطوير خدمه
الانترنت والحصول على مولدات كهرباء لكن
كيف تريد شيئا اخر
صديق كرر مطلب بلده بالحصول على دبابات
اليوبارد الالمانيه المشهود لها في ساحه
المعارك فسعار الحرب لن يهدا قريبا بحسب
الرئيس الاوكراني روسيا تسعى الى مزيد من
التصعيد ولمواجهتها بلته بحاجه الى مزيد
من الاسلحه الحديثه من الغربيه
البدء في تدريب جنود اوكرانيين الاسبوع
المقبل على ارضها في معسكر بولايه
اوكلاهما لتمكينهم من استخدام النظام
باتريوت للدفاع الجويني
اوكرانيا لتشغيل وصيانه والحفاظ على
الدفاعي ومن المتوقع ان تستمر الدوره عده
اشهر في هذه الاثناء تؤكد مصادر مختلفه ان
القوات المواليه لروسيا حققت اختراقا
عسكريا عند خطوط الجبهه في شرق اوكرانيا
بعد جمود استمر لاسابيع طويله رئيس
المجموعه العسكريه الروسيه قال ان قوته
سيطرت على بلده سوليدار من دون ان تتوقف
المعارك في مركز البلده انت تاكد هذا
التطور فسيمنح القوات الروسيه تقدما
باتجاه مدينه محمود الواقعه على بعد بضعتك
فقط